nick saban speaking about one of the
issues relating to devonta smith
specifically his lack of size here's
saban on that topic
i think his performance speaks for
itself
and i'll be honest with you you know
when we recruited demonte smith he
weighed 159 pounds and i wished he was
bigger
and now he weighs 170 pounds and i think
people at the next level are probably
saying i wish he was bigger all right
but
saying all that to say this
there are bigger people who don't
perform anywhere near how he performs
uh there are people that are bigger than
him that don't have the competitive
spirit that he has
nor the competitive toughness
i mean tell me how many receivers are
tougher than he is that block better
that play more physical than he does
so i think maybe
there's a time when you say
this guy really overcomes the fact that
he's not the biggest guy in the world
and he really plays this game really
really well
uh and i don't think anybody could argue
that fact
there's a certain irony with a head
coach talking about the size of a player
while clearly standing on some sort of a
step stool while doing so not that
there's anything wrong with that no
but no no like i got it i got an
instigator in my left ear i got no pro i
don't care how how tall or short anyone
is i really don't i'm just pointing out
the irony of the situation
no i don't well yeah that's true that's
right because as you know i will only
fight with the people that i know i can
beat up but i wouldn't i wouldn't i
wouldn't go i wouldn't go around with
save and i have a feeling he fights
dirty i just think there's an irony to
him talking about a guy's size or lack
thereof while standing on a stool that's
all i'm saying that nothing more uh
anyway
i don't i don't care that devante
smith's 170 pounds the guy can play if
you watched one drive of the national
championship game you know the guy can
play
yeah absolutely and look i think the
more concerning thing is is he going to
go to an offense that can use him
properly or is he going to go to some
place that's going to stand around and
say well you know he's really fast but
he's not that big and i don't know if
our quarterback can throw it down the
field to him or really should he be
going over the middle
they've gotta i really just hope that
smith goes to the kind of team that is
going to utilize him right okay because
i look at what happened to henry ruggs
last year and this could be playbook
driven it could be henry ruggs driven it
could be head coach driven i don't know
but when you have somebody who's that
fast who get who is the first wide
receiver taken off the board and then
has the year that henry ruggs had
there was something wrong there that did
not come into play uh to make him as
good as he should be right so i think
that if as long as smith goes to a place
that knows how to use it right to an
offensive coordinator an offensive play
designer who's going to use him in the
creative ways that he should be utilized
in and he's going to be a great player
in this league but if he doesn't go to
the right spot and he's not utilizing
the right way then people are probably
going to keep bringing up well you know
he's only 170 pounds so that probably
has something to do with the fact that
he's not been the same player in the
league no i think it's going to be so
much scheme driven that determines his
success and i just hope that he goes to
the right place
you're right i remember when desmond
howard came out of
college in 1992 and all of a sudden
instead of facing zone coverages he's
got nfl caliber to shut up you were in
diapers uh and now i am it comes full
circle but uh
um but but he started facing guys at the
line of scrimmage and they'd redirect
him and he couldn't get off the jam and
you know offenses have evolved since
then it's on the offensive coordinator
to move the guy around to create
opportunities get him off the line of
scrimmage get him in the backfield get
him in motion get him running at the
snap so he can get away from that guy
who's up at the line where do you think
then i mean the dolphins make the most
sense right now uh
miles you know we've got quarterback off
one two and three
with the i mean the falcons have julio
jones
but
i you know there's this weird dynamic in
atlanta where the old guard is clearly
coming to an end and a new day is
arriving they've got calvin ridley
they've got julio jones
i would be surprised if they went
devonta smith but i can't rule it out at
number four
i would also be surprised especially
because it seems like things out of
atlanta have started to suggest that
they could draft their next quarterback
after matt ryan at four overall or then
either that or trade back but i think
that
smith would make sense i mean it's not
like when you're drafting you don't want
the best player available based on what
is going on there in atlanta and i think
that arthur smith could be the kind of
uh head coach offensive mind offensive
play caller that would be able to
utilize him in a really really good way
so yeah i could see him going there at
four i mean five with the bengals it
seems like jamar chase is going to be
that guy although if it's me i would
really think about goal with penny
sewell from oregon just because if you
set up that left tackle for joe burrow
boy that could be a match made in heaven
that really you know sets you on a good
path offensively for another decade so
that might be where i would think but
then you get to six and i mean yeah you
could probably pair him with two otago
by lowell once again and then see how
well that thing explodes but i guess
when you have two offensive coordinators
i mean you know it's like what they say
about two uh quarterbacks right if you
have two quarterbacks you have none i
don't know what happens if you have
co-offensive coordinators in the league
in 2021 that that sort of scares me
and i wonder if the dolphins would pass
at six what the lions would do with
seven i mean i don't see many 170 pound
guys that bite kneecaps but the lions uh
you know they they they they made they
made it an almost annual habit of
drafting receivers
a decade ago when matt millen was there
there would be a certain amount of
intrigue if they went with 170 pound
heisman winner but but this is a guy who
can do a lot of things and and look the
last top 10 not very big receiver who
came to the nfl
rams
eight years ago
right tavon austin i mean
look
lack of size doesn't matter unless it
does if you can maneuver if you can play
if you can get it done it doesn't matter
if you're 170 but tavon austin i mean
you know there's a ceiling for every
great college player between what he did
at college and the pro football hall of
fame and for a lot of these guys we
don't find out where that ceiling is
until they smash their head into it and
for austin there there were limits on
what he could do at the nfl level as the
rams find out the hard way even after
they
they paid him a ridiculous extension i
don't know to justify the pick after the
fact but
look there's always risk and that's the
one thing we need to remember miles one
month from the draft
we're going to hear great things about
every one of these guys that gets picked
i think that's part of the contract you
have to sign if you're going to cover
the draft and say all these guys are
great and all these guys are potential
pro bowlers and all these guys are
potential hall of famers we know half of
them are going to bust we know it but we
don't talk about it ahead of time
well because we don't know and here's
what i would say about tavon austin
since i covered him up close for uh i
think four years um they're both in st
louis and then in los angeles i think
that he's exactly the good example of
what i'm talking about where if he is in
that situation where you don't have the
great offensive coordinator and they
have brian shotneimer frank signetti and
then rob boris as offensive coordinators
do you really know any of those names
besides brian schottenheimer no you
don't and part of that is because those
offenses were putrid they were really
really really really really bad offenses
and then sean mcvay got there in 2017
and they started using tavon austin on
that jet motion a little bit more and
that got him a little bit more involved
in the offense but by that time they'd
also upgraded the receiver position so i
just think that like you know you're
saying if you have that smaller guy
there's certainly a ceiling on him and
some of that has to do with talent but i
also just think if you have the right
offensive coordinator who knows how to
utilize that talent in the right way
then it doesn't necessarily matter what
size you are because that size can
sometimes be used as an advantage so
that he's got the size the speed he's
got the heart and you know nick saban
also is sort of doing a sell job because
he's always recruiting and that's part
of his job as a college coach he does an
excellent job at that but i just feel
like this is a little bit of a different
situation than you might have had with
tavon austin at least in the sense that
now with the benefit of hindsight we
know that the rams probably were not the
best spot for him to land
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports